now you guys have talked about you're
walking away from the Avengers but and I
read someone when you thought Energon
snow I'm gonna be cool about this this
is going to be you know it's just a
chapter in my life I'm fine yeah well I
yeah I died maybe you've you've had this
when you get people come up to you in
the street and they say you John snow
and you can like not technically I'm not
John snow no let's go with it I'm John
but I kind of waited I really really had
waited to say the words not anymore
like in a really stoic kind of cool way
like the first person I go no anymore
what really happened was I left set and
I was very emotional and this poor kid
came up to the airport and when you John
snow no
[Applause]
you do have an annoying question well I
don't know about annoying my yes good I
don't know when we were on set with our
movie I was often getting into debates
with Joel fry he was an actor is in the
movie
brilliant I believe that the line from
Lord of the Rings is fly you fools but
he was just constantly telling me it's
run you fools
no it's fly it's definitely fly mm-hmm
but maybe you could clear it for us fly
[Music]
just just for the Nerds and hobbits
among you it it it is not you shall not
pass
that Tolkien didn't write that he wrote
you cannot pass and I got it wrong this
is very exciting
ok first person in the red chair hello
hello what's your name Celine
hello Celine hi jack what story have you
got for us well this is my second visit
to the red chair actually oh I was here
eight years ago right and I told a story
that I thought was really good about
when I was living in France and
something happened with my daughter
however a certain guest on the sofa that
night really did not like my story and
he was rather rude he actually said is
that the best story she could come up
with
who does she bloody think she is funnily
enough my daughter met this person at a
night club recently oh my god it's me
I sent you a message didn't I you did
apologize I know I'm so sorry
[Applause]
what did you perform did a seafood
festival
I mean what [ __ ] show you one know about
was it crap I don't I had a crab fest
and a beginning the stand-up comedy
you're not you're not performing in in
luxury
you know venues that whoever they feel
that they can build the stage and make
money as where you're gone so there was
a crab fest comedians talent people
cracking prayer literally the
frustration that comes from not being
able to open a crab
you're not funny at the same time look
at you here I remember hearing a woman's
older lady who was like she was cracking
crack cuz this is how you Craig Craig
[Music]
tell a joke and a joke doesn't work and
I remember this lady just gone how a
much rather be booth disappointment her
voice she said baby it was I own no baby
[Applause]
with my choice of life you know look at
the hardship that I went through his
help help build me into the person I am
today right I can take so much but I've
been through it all I was I was hit in
the face with a buffalo wing there's no
food
it was it was a it was actually a male
strip club they shut down for comedy for
the first half it was ladies in there
and you know it's just supposed to be us
performing for these women that were
roused up first
I got on stage when they introduced me
and as late as I pull it out I'm here in
to tame who's got kids that stuff trying
to merge it's a kid materials do from
the back he's like that's enough just do
a buffalo wing sauce
there was a woman with a deep voice I
was like who throw it if at the end of
that my man my man first don't
disrespect me
he stood up like I did not I can't
depleted just taking my clothes off but
now we can talk about at poor old Thor
yeah in that film he sort of he did eat
his feelings he definitely ate his way
through his emotions some pictures but
you didn't do that oh no that was my
full Raging Bull Oscar attempt I mean
it's a fat suit lose it now as much
remarkable thing it's a yeah no good
it's a prosthetic like takes kind of
thing which literally I would slip into
it weighed about 60 70 pounds was that
30 40 kilograms with a zip up the back
and they're taking photos of my body and
then every littles prove the hair or
freckle or whatever the hell that was on
that thing it was that's my body in in
like six months time like Thor was
depressed but we was it depressing walk
for you walking around like that I was
so much fun treat you differently I said
yeah every time I step toward the
catering truck they were like no no no
no
the treadmill we were we were doing an
interview yesterday and the journal it
for Good Omens and the journalist said
asked me were you wearing a fat suit for
it this doesn't zip up Bucci she did him
afraid she didn't really recover from
that moment no never so quickly did you
get the pregnant lady thing where people
was want to touch your stomach you got a
lot of cuddles I've had she's had three
kids and often you know they're pregnant
like the belly rub in the supermarket
and Robert Downey got me a fair share
everyone wanted to cuddle me I feel like
Santa Claus yeah yeah you sort of
Avengers on my lap from time to time
just to go back to the hot briefs for a
second Twitter obviously went mad for
the hot priest and it was one scene
better than Neil scene but it was a gasp
over there what was it about that Selah
drove people so crazy I don't really
know I don't really
yeah I think it's quite strange because
the the it was just on Phoebe that scene
yeah you know the camera was just on her
date you actually never see the priest
in that scene so I did think that
there's a touch of the old definitely
you know transgressive of everything yes
so yeah I think just the priest thing
does it for people I don't know I don't
get it yeah bit of concession yeah you
got it licked that's all like just a
couple of tweets these are mildly
streets between 7 hours and 15 days and
I'm still thinking about hot Freeston
fleabag I was at the Catholic Church for
a wedding today and honestly it was too
soon this one went to a lot of trouble
for this one ok this should be so happy
with herself so real life for priests
today they do exist and it does actually
look a bit like it's like a vegan sub
salad I see I know
during a leather jacket right in front
of you
I think this last woman she really went
for it kewal abridge appreciated he bets
used to [ __ ] hell without preset
near my vagina exploded never quite
being able to achieve
[Applause]
[Music]
you